everybody let's give a warm PyCon
welcome to Adam Fletcher and Jonathan
Mortensen all right great our slides
sorry they're not completely fullscreen
that's okay so hi I'm Adam Fletcher and
with me is Jonathan Mortensen so we ran
a company called gyroscope software and
we made developer tools powered by AI
and last year we got an invite to the
Samsung developer conference we weren't
really sure what to do about it right as
a developer tool we wanted the press and
we wanted the exposure from the
conference but also as a developer tool
our booth was destined to be super
boring right
like we'd give you a free t-shirt and
maybe you'd watch like a looping video
of our software in action and that's not
good so we look for something more
exciting
one thing that is obviously more
exciting than a conference booth is
blood sport style underground street
fighting
starring ideally starring the muscles
from Brussels jean-claude van damme
seeking revenge for the death of his
brother that is I think you'll agree
that is clearly more exciting than a
conference booth but we are nerds and as
you can see from our physique we are not
John Clavin done yet it's coming so
instead we decided to see if we could
train an AI to play Street Fighter 2 on
the SNS and then run an AI versus AI
Final Four style tournament during the
conference and today we're gonna talk
about how we used Python to do just that
so first let's start with the overview
of what we're the technologies we use
this is useful so Super Street Fighter 2
turbo runs on the Super Nintendo but in
order to gain the control and speed
necessary to do good AI to train the AI
we couldn't use the actual Nintendo
hardware so we used an emulator called
snes9x and then we used an emulator
environment that let us program the
emulator from afar this is a tool called
bizhawk that the tool-assisted speedrun
community builds right BizTalk is
written in c-sharp and we had to add
some code to that which we'll talk about
in a second and then we use Python to
use Jim a package from open ai and Jim
used some Python code
an agent code that we wrote that uses
Karis RL and tensorflow
so we're just gonna draw it dive
straight into these elements and I'll
describe the results at the end and what
follows is the story of how it actually
happened in terms of code and data
science and so if it's gonna seem a
little disjointed that's because we were
on a voyage of discovery as well and
that's the nature of the story first the
Jim package right so this makes sense as
a starting point
Jim lets us create a representation in
Python about what's happening in the
game and let's our agent interact with
that representation we're using a
technique called reinforcement learning
and this is kind of the simplified
diagram of what reinforcement learning
is right in reinforcement learning you
have a continuous cycle of reinforcement
by having an agent examine the state of
environment then take an action and
seeing if the reward the result of that
action is maximized we're going to talk
more in depth about this but it's useful
to kind of keep this in your head as we
go and the opening I'd Jim project
provides the environment portion of this
and in Jim the environment is what
you're doing reinforcement learning on
and open AI has actually built a number
of good environments for retro-gaming
including for the Atari games and I
think they recently had a retro game and
competition that might still be going on
but they did not provide an environment
for Street Fighter 2 and another big
thing that Jim provides is a very clean
abstraction that can be used for doing
this sort of machine learning right and
I'll talk about the key elements of this
abstraction the action the observation
reward and the two functions step and
reset and we'll go into each one of
these each one of these in some detail
first interesting one is the observation
that is the data that represents the
world the agent will learn about and in
our case it's pretty straightforward
it's Street Fighter 2 just as a human
would see it right it's everything a
human knows it's the timer it's the
health bars it's what your opponent's
doing right and each environment needs
you to define this observation it gives
you gives you Jim gives you tools for
doing that and on the right hand side is
code you don't have to read you
shouldn't care about it just basically
look these are all the things we tracked
this is all the dictionary of all the
things we tracked that represent our
observation right and there's a few ways
to get this so you can get this in some
some papers you read on this sort of
thing you'll get this from image
recognition people will train image
recognizers to see where a character
more points are we actually have the
advantage of using an environment that
gave us direct access to the memory of
the game and so we actually just
extracted these values out of memory but
we didn't do anything that a human
wouldn't do so we didn't we didn't cheat
in any way shape or form we just you
know you can see the health a human can
see the health so we read the health
right it's just a different way to get
access to it and not always but in
general the larger the observation space
you have the more training that will be
required and that that is important
because training cost money and time so
the next critical piece is the action
and actions are the abstraction of what
you can do to change the state right you
send an action to an environment and the
environment will create a new
observation of the state after that
action has occurred practically for us
that's when you press a button on a
controller an action is a button press
on a controller and that changes the
game right you jump you kick etc right
thus our actions are button presses and
the action space for Street Fighter is
interesting it's not actually all of the
possible combinations of buttons on an
SMS controller right but rather all the
possible valid combinations of buttons
eg you can't press left and right at the
same time the emulator let you but we
can't and then we had to simplify this
action space a little bit too because
the the more Lucas like the observation
space the more actions you have
available to you the longer the training
time will take right and here's an
example on the bottom of sort of how we
defined our action space in a multi
discrete for those who wanna know says
like you can do just one of these and
just one of those right and so you can
you can press up and a or up and nothing
but you can't do up a and B fine after
the action you've changed your
observation you get a reward for that
action and roared is what the agent will
try to maximize in our case we spent a
lot of time refining the reward and what
it meant to be rewarded roars are sort
of where the actual interesting part of
MLS so here's some code and again
reading it is not about important but it
just to tell you that the code for the
various reward functions we tried is not
much code and a lot of it is actually a
lot like what a human would think about
it's like did I win the game like you
know naively you're playing Street
Fighter against like your little sister
and they're mashing buttons and beating
you
you're sad you're like I want to win
right so you optimized for winning the
game or maybe you know we in this case
we wanted to optimize for or maybe
trying the Health Net Health change or
you know the health difference right
like these are different things that you
might think about and and often you're
you want a short-term reward because
it's per observation not per game but
you want to maximize this like long-term
goal of winning the game right and we
tried a number of these and what we
ended up settling on after a lot of work
is the simply the delta of health
between the player and their opponent at
each frame right we wanted to reward the
agent for keeping that gap high so
here's a plot of reward over episode and
episode and this came in this case is a
game there's 3,000 games on this plot
right so you can see that speed of
training matters in fact one of the
reasons we didn't use just win-loss the
binary win-loss is a reward function is
that it takes too long to Train based on
that reward finally there are two
functions the gym environment step and
reset and these are used we use these to
control the emulator one step means kind
of move forward to the next frame and
that's where you send all your commands
to the emulator right and then reset is
how you reload the save stage and so
these functions can from the AI worlds
to the emulators world right and
Jonathan's actually gonna go into some
detail about that yeah all right so I'm
gonna talk a little bit about the agent
side of things so we have an environment
thanks to Jim and now we need to agent
to maximize the reward from that
environment so another way is we want
agents to take in these observations as
input and output actions that it
believes are optimal so for this we use
a package called Kara zor-el let's just
talk about Kara zor-el and the abstract
briefly Kara zor-el provides a simple
framework for making agents the code
that I'm showing on the right here is
essentially a random agent again you
have to look at the exact specifics but
it's super super nice interface so
donors showing here is something that
does behaves randomly that's kind of
like the base agent you would ever have
and random is actually a really good
test case lets you make sure that you
know all the pipeline is running and
that you can perform better than random
men so Karis gives you a set of
pre-built agents a base class
you know training testing logging
plotting maybe all those types of things
and the two functions that we really
care about in this abstraction is the
forward function so this says like if I
give you an action I'm sorry I've
returned into action given an
observation right so the agent is
essentially reading the observation
space and does a forward and then the
forward produces an action that it
should be sent to the emulator to do and
then the second thing is the backward
function the backward essentially says
hey what rewarded I just get for taking
that action and then how should I change
my understanding of the world and update
my model so that I can do a better job
next time so the environment from gym
works with Karis in the following way
essentially you create the streetfighter
environment right this is what we use
Jim to create and then you just create
the random agent and then pass in the
environment and then the most important
line here is the agent outfit line this
is effectively kicks off the main loop
where the agent is taking observations
and sending actions and then learning
and getting better over time
so we actually ended up using the DQ n
agent in the Kara zor-el library and so
we've talked extensively about the
environment I'm gonna briefly go into
what DQ n is DQ agent just so you're
gonna get a sense for that it's actually
I'm gonna go into the details of what's
happening inside agent outfit
unless funnier okay before we start
talking about deep Q learning let's
start out with what Q learning is the
caveat here is that in this discussion
I'm gonna be focusing on the intuition
and so there's a lot of bookkeeping in
math that I'm gonna leave out so let's
drop this complex figure and stay at the
intuitive level so I'm gonna describe Q
learning essentially by way of an
example this is a five by five grid
let's say it represents a game of going
from room to room each edge here is a is
a doorway to another room and when I'm
in one room like have a set of actions
between one and four or two and four
actions that allow me to go to another
room so suppose you enter a room and
then you get you find cash in that room
and that's your reward so if we map it
all back right and the reinforcement
learning paradigm Adam talked about the
location on the grid is my observation
the XY coordinate
moving from one room to an adjacent room
essentially opening the doors you're set
your action and then the cash is your
reward so the arrows here then represent
essentially a path of actions taken and
rewards see for that action and the key
thing that q-learning does essentially
the the key learning part before we talk
about the deep part is that it keeps a
lookup table of essentially given every
state that I'm in and every action that
I took what was the reward that I
received so then when I get back to that
same state later or the same observation
later I can go to the lookup table pull
out the answer and say like oh I'm gonna
take this one because that will give me
the most reward so that kind of maps to
the three lines of code I put down here
is essentially I select my best action
or is this lookup table I'm talking
about I send that action to the
environment the environment turns a new
reward and the most important component
is then I update that lookup table with
the state and the action with the new
reward value so sometimes the reward
value changes over time and so you want
to keep that knowledge in this lookup
table so the big takeaway is that to get
to complete that entire lookup table I
have to explore the entire space not
just this one path but every possible
path through the whole thing and so
that's essentially brute force we have
to explore all possible actions and all
possible states and so that's a problem
brute force is bad generally although I
mean whatever gets the job done but
q-learning is basically brute force and
so it's great if we have an infinite
amount of time or if we have tiny
problems but that's usually not the case
and that's definitely not the case here
in Street Fighter instead of having just
25 states we have ten to the twenty five
states and 24 actions it's essentially
you just multiply all the possible
states and that huge dick that Adam
showed earlier and so it's effectively
infinite so brute force is too costly to
do this so deep learning essentially or
essentially yeah I'd say deep learning
allows us to overcome that huge state
space so the twist that deep Q learning
lets you do is that instead of trying
all possible actions and figuring out
the reward for each action we try and
predict the reward even if we haven't
seen it and we do that prediction using
a neural network so for example it say
just
to go on this path starting in the lower
right and just go straight up I might
predict that going straight up yields a
reward of two that might not actually be
the case but I can predict that without
not act without having to actually do it
and so another way to think about it is
that again at the intuitive level of the
neural network is interpolating and
extrapolating using simple math rather
than just being a look at being a lookup
table so this essentially what happens
we replace the neural net with the
lookup table with a neural network and
the neural network gives back actions
that should be taken and then learns
over time based on what actually happens
so in this case if I went up and I got a
zero then I'd tell the neural network
hey I got a zero you should do a better
job interpolating extrapolating so
that's a brief digression into the deep
Q learning approach and how the agent
works the last key part of the
architecture is a controller so this is
the thing that translates actions to the
environment to actual commands that the
gaming bellator runs and Adams gonna
talk about that thanks Jonathan
great so first of all look how great is
the Python 3 standard library like come
on it's really great right like we we
had to come up with a system for
communicating back and forth between
this emulator and what we just found was
like ok we'll just use TCP socket server
and that just worked and then we're like
ok well we need some state management's
and thread management and a threading
module that just worked and then the
Sigma primitives inside the 30 module
for signaling between threads also just
worked right this is great so you're not
meant to read this code but it's more a
sense of how much code we actually had
to write just to communicate back and
forth and is not very much and it
control it contains the entirety of our
protocol between the emulator and our AI
right and we just sent JSON back and
forth between the emitter but it's it's
really nice right and that's one of the
beautiful things about Python this was
super fast to do and so the wind at the
command go right so we sent this JSON
command somewhere well that we sent them
to a thing called a biz Hawk and that's
what controlled the emulator right and
BizTalk
suck in stupid socket didn't have that
and then we had to write the code needed
to read from streetfighter memory we
needed to write the code to push the
buttons we got from JSON that the Python
sent over also we had to learn C sharp
which we didn't know before
this I gotta say see sure pretty nice
language I was surprised at how easy
this was all to do and I have to thank
the bit sock developers for the just
general cleanliness and organization of
their code we have open source to the
the code we used in here it's I just
don't go read it unless you're gonna
make a pull request we did it fast and
so the limitations of the emulator code
actually the meant that we had to try a
bunch of techniques before settling on
the socket code we just showed you so
bit sock actually contains Lua
interpreter in it which is great but the
law of interpreter they have doesn't
support Network IO it does support file
IO and sequel light so we did try to
shove all this together via like writing
to a file reading from file or write
into a database row reading from it
that's a terrible idea don't do that it
was also very slow it we were able to
run the emulator basically at 60 frames
a second using file IO 120 using sequel
Lite and and finally when we switch to
Python socket server we got 450 frames
per second in well we could run three
training of training yeah we could do
three three games training at a time on
a Windows machine in Google Cloud this
actually saved us a ton of money so
because we're training in the cloud
right that's money a time performance is
a huge feature right and Python was able
to get a significant performance scans
now great we have four and fifty frames
per second we have a fast performing
system we had a good architecture but
now we actually have to Train like we
have to do that part of AI where you
teach it things here's a tiny snippet
and I cannot emphasize the tiny nosov it
of the results of the actual training we
spent hundreds of cloud computers and
human hours tweaking all of these
parameters it's just like a matrix with
all the parameters we messed with and
and to figure out what works well like
deep learning is great but it is also
sometimes alchemy right which is
unfortunate and we tried to you know we
tweaked the neural network parameters we
treat the environment we tweaked the
number of games tweaked feature
representation training parameters etc
etc we tried to be relatively scientific
about it changing one thing at time but
in the end you know we were wrong about
pretty much every assumption we made to
start right it's fine that's what this
is how it goes but we did build a system
that let us iterate incredibly fast
being wrong and that actually was a
really helpful thing to have done so
about three days before the conference
to our relief we finally got an agent
trained that did well and you'll see on
the screen if the video loads we get to
watch some awesome street fighter stuff
this is after three thousand games we
have an eighty percent win rate the AI
is on the left its dhalsim and what
you'll see here is some interesting
stuff dodging blocking special moves
backing away
you know avoiding damage winning the
game with the fireball it's pretty dope
right it's it's pretty cool we were very
excited when I and now here's our non
boring booths
with all of our homemade signs look we
were startup right the laptop actually
that you see here is actually training
agents displays showing the training of
four agents at a time so people can
watch it happened and then when we
initially trained our agents actually
against the Super Nintendo CPU and three
star difficulty and then later we
trained them against each other at the
conference we ran a Final Four style
tournament like I said and to see which
was BOTS we trained was best so we had a
competition inside this if you if you
guessed which which agent was gonna win
you could win a Super Nintendo classic
for those Super Street Fighter fans out
there you'll notice that em bison is not
on this bracket that's because he's okay
he's totally over parsh
right and our AI figured this out really
fast looks like like right away and we
watched the first tournament were like
oh this is just not good like it was
just a clear sweep and so we banned him
from the second tournament we ran due to
performance enhancing drugs aka his code
so the second and the second tournament
we ran actually ended up going to Saget
and if you want to know who the best
character play as well if you are an AI
it's an Bison I don't know if you're
human I'm I am terrible at this game um
and I have to say like for those of you
who might have to do this sort of thing
in the future people loved this idea
right they loved watching all these
matches this little kid over on the
right hand kind with his like handovers
heart like he was like crying when he
lost when his character lost in the
tournament he we were so sad but he
loved every minute of he would just come
and watch the booth when we weren't even
having the tournament just to see the
characters fighting we had about 80
people
just kind of screaming and yelling
during the whole tournament I mean it's
a great way to do it
and so much better than a t-shirt and
like a video of our software there's a
lot to love about Python and artificial
intelligence and machine learning I mean
there's a lot to love about Python in
general we know the at the iteration
speed the batteries included nature of
it right the standard library good
abstractions like we're all here for
that reason but Karis Jim tensorflow
scifi these are world-class tools that
are easy to use
they're free they're community supported
it's amazing right it's great and it's
actually not just Python that we love
its programming in general and one thing
I in particular love about programming
is sometimes I make really hilarious
mistakes all right so this is our this
is a chart of our AI it's winrate
playing against a literally motionless
opponent so it's we start out really
strong like we win a bunch of the first
couple hundred games but then how do we
lose I don't even know how we end up
losing I think we just ran into the
opponent and we died over and over again
right but but but actually it's a great
outcome right its scientific it's an
important one and we learn from it and
it and it was pretty funny and we all
learned sort of from funny failures like
this and so like I want to help new and
experienced programmers understand that
it's okay and normal to make mistakes
like this so I'm asking you guys some of
the experience people are the new people
to tweet out your funniest programming
fails right like with hashtag Python
2018 and then hashtag reward function
this is my joke on us giving you a prize
for this and by the end of the weekend
like the person with the most retweets
will find will track you down and send
you a Super Nintendo classic because I
think that'd be pretty fun you can tweet
we're at blue voyant but just tweet
about it and tell us about the times
you've made mistakes make sure they're
yours not someone else's make sure
they're educational and funny all right
because we want to teach people it's
fine like yeah you're gonna screw it up
and that's the best part of a
programming it's completely safe and you
get to learn that way so thank you if
you have any questions we hope our story
was interesting in fact we have another
one so the company we were talking about
gyroscope well you got acquired by an
amazing security firm called blue
buoyant I would be remiss to say we are
hiring if I didn't say that come talk to
us about this come talk to us ask us
questions right after during the
talk and then we're around all weekend
you can come find us at lunch tomorrow
if you want to talk about AI in general
and yeah thank you very much happy to
take questions thank you so much guys we
got a few minutes for questions so
please come to the microphone if you've
got one this one frightens front and
center here I would ask you use this
time only for questions directed at the
speakers if you want to talk about
anything longer have specific add-on
comments feel free to catch them in the
hall after the talk thank you Hey quick
question when you guys made all this did
you guys account for like say peak human
performance in peak human reactions like
in a 60 FPS game I understand it to be
like a 15 frame 15 frame delay between
inaction and someone being able to react
to that yeah great question and the
answer is yes we did so yeah I actually
only acts every 20 frames because
actually for a number of reasons one is
that the training would have taken too
long if we acted every frame so that's
important but also against humans it's
it's pretty much only fair to fair to do
that this would just I think over time
if we just trained this it would just
destroy every human I could just it
wouldn't even be posted if we if we
enabled like every frame thank you
question so the question I had was about
like a time-delayed attack you know so
if ryu like throws a fireball from the
other side of the screen and then
coincidentally ducks you know when it
hits the opponent if you're only just
considering that one frame could your AI
not learn that you know ducking equals
damage to the opponent so the the
essentially the rewards and the failures
are propagated back so you there's a
it's kind of like an exponential curve
but yeah it will eventually figure out
that like this this observation that I
made like ten frames in the future will
then like suffer the actual consequence
okay thanks did they learn special moves
on their own or did you intentionally do
anything with them they learn special
moves on their own so they just have the
key presses right and they break they
have every 20 frames they can insert
like a key press pair essentially one
Joey pad and one butt
and so they actually like that that move
that I show at the end just started with
like key presses and you figured out how
to shoot the fireball thank you
hey two quick questions
did you consider it hurt boxes or hit
boxes and in the machine learning now
I'm okay and then second have you
considered challenging and professional
players with your BOTS yes let me let me
get the me answer that question so the
we were able to know the X&Y coordinate
of every player and so that was like a
way for them to figure out how close
they were to each other and when they
should be doing moves or not
and I think they also knew what the who
their opponent was so they're kind of
indirectly learning where the hitbox is
and then we yeah we've actually talked
to one of the top five players after we
did this and had a fun blog post he
wanted to compete against it so we need
to set up a tournament was it tiger
there's actually a whole nother funny
story about potentially doing a
marketing campaign for l'oréal by making
an AI bought anyhow again to come talk
to us okay come talk to us that doesn't
do anything for me
[Applause]
how much did the training cost like
could I do it on my own computer yeah
sure so actually we did a bunch of it on
our own computer with a we initially
didn't even do it with GPU optimizers we
just did it on like a local Windows
machine which it was a fairly powerful
gaming machine but we actually didn't
use the GPU in the end we did use Google
Cloud compute so that we could have lots
of computers going to Train all of the
agents all in parallel but you could do
the training on your own computer and it
wouldn't cost you how much are we really
just paid so that we could do it in
parallel you know if we had like 40
Windows machines at home we were down at
that what - how much did the cloud cost
I mean I think we use the free
subscription there's the there's you
know there's the first you know 720
hours for you whatever and then Adam
used to work at Google so maybe we got a
little extra but they're essentially
each game took about three hours to
train at 450 frames per second and then
you could train essentially three or
four games in parallel on the same
computer so well thanks
I'm I'd like to ask about sort of what
your guys's backgrounds are like like
your academic backgrounds cuz I've
noticed that a lot of machine learning
and AI jobs seem to require PhDs
okay so I'll answer it first and I will
answer for him - so my background is I
actually have a business degree and but
I was a site reliability engineer at
Google for many years and ran very
large-scale systems and I software
engineer for a long long time so and and
still do some of those things when I'm
not in meetings and however Jonathan
Mortensen over here is better known as
dr. Jonathan Mortensen he has a PhD from
Stanford he never talked about it but
you should cook when you see him
tomorrow or ask him questions address
him as dr. he really likes that I don't
think that you need PhD to be my PhD was
like in biomedicine doing like you know
EHR analysis so like you don't need it
just to be clear I don't think that
there's any gate there one interesting
that happened to us we got an email from
some students in Pakistan who you
our code to do this as their one of
their undergraduate projects they just
kind of redid our work and and they you
know they don't have a PhD so but they
were able to figure out different
techniques and different reward
functions and things like that thank you
hi there so one of the things that's
been taking like the retro gaming
community by storm is randomized games
so things like Super Mario Brothers 3
randomizer Link to the Past randomizer
so what I'm wondering is how might a I
adapt to games were some of the
underlying parts of it is randomized but
the rules remain the same I think it's a
really a question about how well
characterized the observations are and
so what can what can happen when you're
doing machine or anything right is like
you kind of learn you overfit right you
kind of learn exactly how the game plays
like even if you know the rules that
you're like oh I saw this frame and I
know that if I see this room I just have
to do this thing next instead of
actually interpreting what's going on in
the frame I think if you have a good
representation of that state space I
think it should as long as the rules are
consistent I should learn okay thank you
I have a question about how you chose
the hyper parameters you showed us that
spreadsheet and it sounded like there
was a lot of hand tuning to kind of get
the magic combination just generally
what are your thoughts on on I guess
algorithmic or more automated ways of
finding hyper parameters whether it's
genetic algorithms or something else and
and and generally speaking when do you
feel those types of methods are going to
be successful versus when you kind of
have to tweak numbers by hand that's a
complicated question I think yes you
want to use some heuristics to do
essentially a grid search you can't do
oftentimes you came to a foolproof force
grid search but using some heuristics
which say oh if I make this tweak the
performance goes up I mean essentially
it's not really maybe sometimes
parameter optimization is a convex
problem but it's usually not so you got
to explore the space hand tuning there's
still place for that and there was a
place here which was that you know one
of the things that we were tuning was
frame skip
and that requires some intuition about
how you play the game and making sure
that that lines up all together so I
mean I think that machine learning isn't
a silver bullet you still need to
understand the domain that you're trying
to model and behave in and so there's a
place for both but using grid search is
almost so great as well I mean if you
can do things in compute that's cheaper
than like your time then you should do
it that way and if you can also add some
of your intuitions you should too so
it's kind of non-answer answer all right
yes thank you that's all the time we
have for questions now if you'd like to
meet with the speakers in the hall
afterwards feel free to do so thank you
very much everyone appreciate it
[Applause]